watch the silver eye on top of the arc  just watch every time it swings let's  pretend we're unraveling a piece of  string  little by little let's pretend that  piece of string is time unraveling  minute by minute second by second going  backwards time slipping away everything  around you this house my voice your  mother all these things are getting  further away we're going back through  your life back to when you started  school when you first learned to walk  when you were just a baby  back to the day you were born  back to the time before this body a  milonga speaking to miles I'm speaking  to the person who has taken residence  inside his body  he came uninvited tell me if you can  hear my voice  my ass  my house what's wrong  mommy I'm scared  come here baby  [Music]  [Music]